[Musik]
knochenjobs in Hitze und Gefahren
ein Spiel mit dem Feuer in der Gießerei
Köhler Arbeiten auf glühenden Kohlen
und muss da oben dann die Erde drauf
werfen da ist auch noch ein Arbeit
besonders explosiv ist der Job als
kampfmittelrheuma
das ist die brennende Füllung von
Brandbomben auch Napalm genannt
diese Arbeitsplatz gehört zu den
staubigsten und heißesten in Deutschland
die Eisengießerei in Goslar
Felix Krause ist Schmelzer pro Tag
schmelzt er bis zu 5 Tonnen Eisen im
Ofen ein alle Zutaten hat er genau
abgewogen
[Applaus]
ja man muss noch ein bisschen gucken was
man reinschmeißt kommt doch einfach von
Gießen möchte
was zum Beispiel
verschiedene Sorten einfach gucken mit
Silizium und Kohle und man kann die aber
auch noch reisen weil man muss so ein
bisschen aufpassen
der Hauptbestandteil roh Eisen heute
sollen daraus 57 Gussteile werden
Pumpengehäuse Türrahmen für eine
Chemieanlage und eine Schlacke Wanne für
ein zinkwerk oft sind es Einzelstücke
so ich wollte auch noch mit Metall
machen Beruf so als Schlosser oder mit
deiner Wahl ist nicht normal
das hat mir sehr viel Spaß gemacht
außerdem bin ich hier
möchte doch was anderes arbeiten
fast 10 Jahre hat Felix Krause nun schon
den Job rein und den Lärm und den Dreck
hat er sich inzwischen gewöhnt ein
Bürojob das wäre nichts für ihn
[Musik]
ja grüß Gott immer noch ein bisschen
Handarbeit gefragt weil gar nicht alles
so rein geht dann muss man halt noch ein
bisschen aufschieben
viereinhalb Tonnen Eisen und
legierungsanteile wie Kohle und Silizium
sind jetzt im Ofen
nächste Aufgabe die Pfanne
daraus gießen Sie später das flüssige
Eisen in die Form
Felix Krause muss sie sauber machen
quasi der Abwasch vom Vortag
ja man muss man alles wieder Sortieren
von gestern nach Gießen und ein bisschen
aufräumen wir haben die Pfannen sauber
gemacht alles wieder fertig gemacht dann
fürs Leben
Produktionsleiter Andreas Jacobi muss
dafür sorgen dass die Mengen für den
Eisenguss immer stimmen schon jetzt muss
er planen mit welchen Pfannen später
welche Formen gegossen werden ist das
Eisen erst heiß ist dafür keine Zeit
mehr
überlegen mit der aufteiler
heute gibt es ein Problem eigentlich
wollte er nur mit den kleinen Pfannen
Gießen ihren Volumen reicht diesmal aber
nicht aus
die Form sind täglich
individuell zusammengestellt also das
ist nicht jeden Tag dasselbe da muss man
halt schauen wie man das flüssige Eisen
nachher in die Pfannen aufteilt weil ja
wo es ein bestimmtes Fassungsvermögen
haben und die Behandlung auch nur einer
bestimmten Gewichtsklasse erfolgen kann
aber wir können wir uns im Sommer 1300
bis 1600 behandeln also muss ich das
dann irgendwie
übereinbringen das was vernünftig
abgegossen kriegen hat
also heute doch die große Pfanne und
danach noch ein Problem
diese Stück haben sie gestern gegossen
jetzt ist es frisch aus der Form
gekommen geht die durch mein Gott
sieht ganz nach Lufteinschluss aus das
ist für eine
puppenherstelleranteil der wollte das
eilig haben das sieht natürlich
muss man halt noch mal schnell einen
nachmachen das ist ungünstige ist dass
die Stückzahlen auch sehr gering ist
also da kommt nur zwei Stück vorne und
wenn wir davon einen Ausschuss haben ist
das natürlich Mist
Schmelzer Felix krause hat die beiden
kleinen Pfannen schon sauber gemacht wir
sind leichter zu bewegen fassen aber nur
maximal 700 und 1000 Kilo Eisen das
reicht heute auch mit mehreren
gießgängen nicht
Leute
jetzt soll auch noch die große Pfanne
zum Einsatz kommen eine kleine Pfanne
brauchen sie trotzdem
Nachteile ist natürlich dass die große
Pfanne dagegen viereinhalb Tonnen rein
dass sie nicht ganz ausgefüllt ist also
eigentlich wäre es schon günstiger wenn
man möglichst kleine Pfannen die er voll
ist dann ist der Wärmeverlust auch nicht
so hoch aber
die Situation ist halt so das war auf
die große umsteigen müssen damit aus
Eisen komplett unterkriegen jetzt muss
Felix Krause noch eine Pfanne Schrauben
die Reste vom Vortag müssen raus
wenn ihr hier nicht richtig sauber macht
dann landen schlackerreste und
Verunreinigungen im Guss
der direkt der löst sich ja wieder
ganz passiert dass der ganze Dreck mit
den Frühstück kommt was er nun nicht
sein soll
schlimmsten Fall ist es Ausschuss das
Schrot das ist ja noch nicht Sinn und
Zweck der ganze Übung
und darum wird auf jeden Tag vernünftig
gewartet sauber gemacht
zum Abschluss schmiert Felix Krause die
Pfanne mit der sogenannten schlichte ein
ein feuerfester Anstrich der schützt die
Pfanne vor der Hitze die Butter beim
Braten
in wenigen Stunden wird sich zeigen ob
die Pfannen dem Eisen standhalten
heiß wird es auch in Nordrhein-Westfalen
bei Netphen im Siegerland
rauchenden Haufen wird Holz zu Kohle ein
Kohlemeiler
Kühler Reinhold Wagner und Maria
Theresia Sting sind unterwegs zu ihrem
Mailand sie wollen wissen ob sie heute
die Holzkohle ernten können
seit sieben Tagen verkohlt das Holz
bereits solange der Meiler brennt hat
Reinhold Wagner gut zu tun
[Musik]
ich mache jetzt hier so
rauchlöcher noch weil der ist ja hier am
gar werden da ist er schon da
aber hier hat er noch bestimmt noch
einen Tag hat er hier noch zu zu glühen
und da mache ich ihm immer mal wieder
neue Löcher dort rein man merkt ja auch
hier ist noch Holz
da ist noch Holz
von daher
hat er hier noch einen Tag zu tun
die Glut darf nicht ausgehen das Holz
darf aber auch nicht verbrennen selbst
wenn es friert regnet oder bei Wind mit
den Löchern steuert der Köhler die
Sauerstoffzufuhr
ob das Holz fertig verkohlt ist das
verrät ihm der Rauch
die Farbe vom Rauch zeigt mir wie weit
der Mailer ist an der Stelle
das blau wird
ist blau wird so dann ist er da in der
Stelle ist er so weit durch da ist eine
Farbe da ist dann auch noch ein verkohl
noch hier ist er schon fast durch hier
unten
die thesis vorher schon ziemlich außen
wo es hier so dunkel richtig blau wird
wie kann ich reinstecken da ist kein
Holz mehr da ist nur noch Kohle hier
und
Diät ist natürlich noch ziemlich heiß
hier die gelbe Erde die sehr heiß also
da muss man schon aufpassen dass man
sich da nicht dran verbrennt die sehr
heiß also ich persönlich habe mir damals
den ganzen Fuß verbrannt
Reinhold Wagener macht die Arbeit seit
über 60 Jahren schon als Kind hat er
eigene Meile aufgestellt seit drei
Jahren ist auch Maria Theresia Sting an
meiner dabei
nach dem Tod ihrer Partner lernten sich
beide kennen
für mich war es vorher auch ja da
rauchten Meiler das war's dann und jetzt
habe ich mal so dieses ganze Handwerk
kennengelernt weil
ja gut ich habe sowas wie ein
Ausbildungsvertrag und ich habe jetzt
schon viel mit dem kohlenmaler auch
gemacht beim Aufstellen beim Ausräumen
beim Abkühlen
es macht mir Spaß jetzt richtig schön
[Musik]
wenn der Meiler gar wird bilden sich
immer mal wieder von selbstlöchern dann
kommt zu viel Sauerstoff in den Mailer
hier muss Reinhold Wagner schnell
reagieren
[Musik]
wenn das jetzt größer wird kann es sein
dass da
dass da Holz for brennt und nicht Kohle
wird hier oben das Loch das ist zu groß
das kann man so nicht lassen aber
einfach Erde drauf Schaufeln das geht
nicht
[Musik]
dann siehst du die Erde durch die Kohle
und ich das Holz durch und da geht es
Feuer aus die Knut geht dann aus und
dann erst Heu und dann wieder Erde damit
nicht sage ich mal die Erde durchfließt
so hole ich immer eine Schaufel wo muss
ich hin oben da oben
ich hole meine Schaufel
Reinhold Wagner achtet darauf dass die
verschwehlung des Holzes zur Kohle
möglichst lange dauert nur dann gehen
Feuchtigkeit und alle Gase aus dem Holz
das Ziel möglichst reiner Kohlenstoff
wichtig ist für den Köder also da mit
dem Meile auch bisschen kämpft dass er
gut nach unten durchglüht
da ist so eine Kunst und jeder Köder der
der ist dann stolz wenn es gut geklappt
hat
[Musik]
mit etwas Glück und gutem Wind kann er
heute noch die Holzkohle ernten
in Deutschland und Österreich liegen
noch mehr als 100.000 Bomben Blindgänger
aus dem Zweiten Weltkrieg im Boden dazu
Unmengen Flak und gefechtsmunition
Sprengkörper mehrere Meter unter der
Erde aufzuspüren und auszugraben ist ein
gefährlicher Knochenjob in Leobersdorf
30 Kilometer südlich von Wien haben die
kampfmittelberger der Firma EOD
munitionsbergung den Auftrag eine
Baustelle auf Munition abzusuchen die
Gegend zwischen Wien und Wiener Neustadt
wurde im Zweiten Weltkrieg stark
bombardiert denn es gab viel Industrie
Stefan pleiner und seine Kollegen machen
Bohrlöcher für die sogenannte
tiefensondierung die Herausforderung an
diesen Stellen ist halt dass der
Untergrund sehr schotterig ist wenig
Leben Anteile weniger bindige Anteile
hat das heißt bei der polloxonierung tun
uns hier meistens etwas etwas schwerer
auch tatsächlich die sonder bis in die
Tiefe von sechs Meter in der
Fliegerbomben liegen können hinunter zu
bekommen weil einfach da
zusammenfällt und deswegen ist der
Aufwand hier etwas größer wie in einer
Gegend wo zum Beispiel nur Sand oder
Lehmboden vorhanden ist an dieser Stelle
gibt es keinen akuten bombenverdacht der
Bauherr möchte aber auf Nummer sicher
gehen dass hier tatsächlich keine
Munition im Boden liegt
Thomas Bauer ist räumstellenleiter
munitionsbergung ist nicht nur
gefährlich sondern auch körperlich
anstrengend
fünf Jahre ganz normaler Arbeitstag
mit der Zeit wird
und
schon wieder mal wieder ein bisschen
normaler Arbeitstag in die Bohrlöcher
kommen Plastikrohre die die teure
magnetsonde schützen sollen dann lassen
die kampfmittelberger die Sonde ab beim
Hochziehen misst das Gerät Störungen im
Erdmagnetfeld die auf ein metallisches
Objekt im Boden hindeuten
die Messergebnisse können sich dem
Männer direkt anschauen auch die
ungefähre Größe und Tiefe des Objekts
zeigen die Messwerte eine Anomalie gaben
die kampfmittelräume das Objekt aus
da war ich jetzt nicht zu schlecht aus
jetzt beginnt der andere Teil von
unserer Arbeit die sogenannte Auswertung
die Messungen zeigen keine Störungen im
Erdmagnetfeld eine Bombe liegt hier
nicht da sind sich die kampfmittelräumer
sicher nach knapp zwei Stunden Arbeit
können die Männer einpacken ab jetzt
kann die Baufirma angstfrei arbeiten
Feierabend haben die kampfmittelräume
noch lange nicht diese Einsatz war nur
der Auftakt Thomas lädt die jeweils 40
Kilogramm schweren bohrschnecken wieder
ein
[Musik]
etwa 800 solcher Aufträge hat die Firma
im Jahr bis zu 150 Mal finden Sie dabei
scharfe Munition jetzt geht es weiter
auf die nächste Baustelle fahren wir
noch lichtenwörth
das ist ca 20 Minuten von da entfernt
hier war nichts zu holen an der nächsten
räumstelle haben die Voruntersuchungen
allerdings vielversprechende Messdaten
ergeben
Eisengießerei Goslar der Schmelzofen
läuft bis zum Mittag soll das Eisen
flüssig und auf 1.550 Grad sein
wir stellen mal Öl und Sauerstoff ein
man Fahrt immer ein bisschen langsamer
an also wenn man hier gut sehen so so
fahren wir mal zum Anfang wenn man
Sachen von einer guten halben Stunde
oder dreht man immer ein bisschen höher
so
macht eisenschmelzer Felix Krause hier
einen Fehler kann das den Ofen
beschädigen
und gleich volle Pulle reinhauen dann
kann das sein dass die über drei ist
und das ist dann nicht so gut weil wir
können sich davon außen gar nicht sehen
und im schlimmsten Fall läuft das Eisen
dann dahinter und wir haben ein Problem
und das wollen wir nicht also fahren wir
langsam an und drehen Stück für Stück
höher und das alles kontrollierlich
der Ofen ist aus Stahl einer lehmartige
Ofen stampfmasse schützt die Ofenwand
von innen alle 200 Chargen muss neue
stampfmasse an die Ofenwand dieser Ofen
ist schon mehr als 25 Jahre alt kann man
noch mal weggehen aber wenn das Eisen
flüssig ist muss immer einer hier
bleiben das darf keiner dass da oben
darf nie alleine bleiben weil wenn was
passiert muss immer einer Dauer sein
schnell reagieren können abschalten oder
sonst irgendwas keine mal passieren dass
der Ofen irgendwo an irgendeiner Stelle
durch geht und dann kann er hier ist
dann dreht er sich ja jetzt so wie jetzt
weiter und das Eisen das läuft immer
raus
so von daher überall auch Öl ist die
ölschläuche und die anfangen zu brennen
und dann
riesenschaden in der Halle nebenan bauen
die gießerei-mechaniker die Gussform
Produktionsleiter Andreas Jacobi hat
einen Eilauftrag der Guss eines
pumpenteils vom Vortag hatte ein Loch
und muss dringend neu gemacht werden
zuerst müssen sie aber die Form für den
Guss noch mal bauen mit einer Mischung
aus Quarzsand und furanharz
die wird um die Modelle geschüttet und
härtet aus jede Form lässt sich nur
einmal verwenden
das Spannende an am Handformen und an
dem was wir hier machen ist eigentlich
dass wir wechselnde Teile haben und dass
das im Grunde schon einige hundert Jahre
so funktioniert also Kanonen und
ähnliches wurden auch schon so gegossen
dass man im Grunde eigentlich nur ein
negativen Hohlraum baut und dann
flüssiges Metall rein gießt natürlich
war war man damals nicht ganz so
filigran das deswegen wird die Kanone
auch so dick also man hat Vorschein
einfach die dicker gemacht um die
Festigkeit zu kriegen bist du drei
Stunden dauert es bis der Sand hart ist
dann können die Gießer die Sandformen
vom silbernen Modell lösen
57 Formen müssen sie heute für den Guss
vorbereiten
mit 24 Jahren zählt Justus Siemes zu den
jüngsten hier
viele wollen ja eher studieren ins Büro
halt ruhigere Arbeit und allem
und deswegen kommen wahrscheinlich keine
Nachwuchs mehr so richtig nach denn
genau
damit das Gussteil später eine glatte
Oberfläche hat hat Justus Sims die
Formen mit dem feuerfesten Anstrich
eingepinselt jetzt muss er die einzelnen
formenteile zusammensetzen das sind wir
bei uns das ist ein Kern der wird später
im Buschweg dein Hohlraum erzeugen den
man damit erreichen wollen hier wird
sozusagen das Eisen dann später
reinkommen wird einmal durch den Filter
fließen da werden Dreck und
verunreiniger noch mal durchgefiltert
dann über den Anschnitt in die Form und
hier sieht man dann später läuft
sozusagen das Eisen durch und dann im
Oberkasten auch noch mal hier wird der
Kern dann später drin sitzen noch mal
ist die Form komplexer muss Justus 7s
mehrere Kerne einlegen was ist bei dir
noch zwei Stunden bis zum Guss dann
müssen die Sandformen dem 1550 Grad
heißen Eisen standhalten
[Musik]
der Ofen läuft jetzt seit zweieinhalb
Stunden
wie heiß ist darin ist weißschmelzer
Felix Krause nicht genau eine
Temperaturanzeige gibt es nicht aber für
eine Probe ist es noch zu früh
man hört es ja das eisenkräuter der noch
da drinne
und er hat auch seine Erfahrungen dass
unsere
Menge fertig
die Arbeit am Ofen nicht ungefährlich
jeder muss Felix Krause auch die
Schläuche an Brenner kontrollieren nicht
nur Sauerstoff und Öl fließen hierdurch
auch Wasser
damit der Brenner nicht verbrennt quasi
der ist ja wassergekühlt dann muss man
ab und zu mal drauf gucken worauf achten
dass auch alles funktioniert Wasser kann
ja auch mal heiß werden da fängt der
Schlauch an zu tanzen und dann haben wir
ein Problem
eigentlich haben wir dafür eine
signaltröte dass man das so heiß wird
dann trötet die aber es kann ja mal sein
also immer kontrolle ist besser in einer
Stunde soll es losgehen noch einmal
erhöht Felix Krause die Sauerstoff und
Ölzufuhr bis zum Gießen darf er den Ofen
jetzt nicht mehr allein lassen
zurück in Netphen im Siegerland
Reinhold Wagener hält den coole Meiler
seit sieben Tagen am Brennen eigentlich
sollte die Kohle heute fertig sein
solange der Rauch aber noch weiß ist ist
noch Feuchtigkeit im Holz
siehst
es kommt
immer nach weißer Rauch
und immer wieder bilden sich große
Löcher damit die Holzkohle nicht
verbrennt muss Reinhold Wagener jedes
dieser Löcher schließen
[Musik]
mit der Köhlerei führte den Beruf seines
Vaters weiter
mein Vater sagt immer wenn einer fragt
ja was kommt denn aus so normal raus
Jungs sag einfach was es Feuer übrig
lässt weil man kann nie sagen es kommt
so viel oder so viel raus ist jedes Mal
anders und es kann auch mal schlecht
laufen da hat man viel Holz wird nicht
zu Kohle wird
Reinhold Wagner ist dieses Jahr 70 Jahre
alt geworden manchmal stellte nur einen
Meiler im Jahr auf
so
was
für uns
bauteiler im Miniformat
ungefähr hier
oder er macht mit dem Schuh zwei drei
vier
so da macht er hier mal
heute sonst mache ich mir so einen Kerbe
weil ich weiß
da steht mein erster Block und jetzt
gehe ich mit dem
Zirkel weiter
[Musik]
es muss rund sein
nachher auch gleichmäßig runterglühen
wenn ich jetzt hier so ein so ein
Geschwür im mache und hier habe ich zu
wenig und der Schacht ist hier ich habe
da doppelt Holz wie hier da ist er hier
schon längst gar und da hinten habe ich
noch gar nicht angefangen zu glühen da
muss er schön rund sein
[Musik]
in der Mitte des Meilers stapelt
Reinhold Wagener das Holz zu einem
Schacht über den wird der Meiler später
von oben angezündet
von außen wird eine Blut gemacht und die
wird dann hier in den Schacht eingefüllt
hier unten drin würde ich vor sich hin
und da muss ich den die Glut immer
wieder schüren
[Musik]
gehört die kühlerhütte früher haben die
Köhler hier den ganzen Sommer verbracht
auch heute noch schläft Reinhold Wagener
auf Dir wenn er einen neuen Meiler baut
darf er ihnen den ersten Nächten nicht
allein lassen
da muss man in alle vier fünf Stunden
nachfüttern das ist ja wie so ein Ofen
der musste erstmal heiß werden und wenn
der dann Temperatur hat fängt der an zu
glühen und wenn der AN zu verchronen
fängt dann bilden sich am Anfang auch
noch Holzgas und diese können auch schon
mal verpuffen und dann kann die Erde
runterrutschen wenn man da nicht da ist
dann kann das Holz auch verbrennen jetzt
müssen Reinhold Wagener und Maria
Theresia stehen noch das Holz für den
minimaler stapeln ein Maler kann auch
mehrere Meter hoch gebaut werden
zum Schluss decken Sie das gestapelte
Holz mit Heu und Erde ab
alles muss dicht sein nur bei wenig
Sauerstoff wird Holz zu Holzkohle
in Guntramsdorf bei Wien Graben die
munitionsberger nach einem Blindgänger
auf dem Gelände möchte ein
Lebensmittelhersteller eine neue
Produktionshalle bauen
die kampfmittelräume haben Bohrloch
Sondierungen vorgenommen einer von
vielen Luftangriffen auf das nahe
flugzeugmotorenwerk waren 23 August 1944
auf dem Luftbild vom 25 August fanden
auswerte einen blindgänger-
um diesen Punkt herum haben die
kampfmittelräumer ihre Messungen
vorgenommen 57 Bohrungen für 57
Messungen und gleich bei der sechsten
Bohrung ist dann tatsächlich in einer
Tiefe von sechs Meter eben
ein Verdacht
entstanden den es eben gilt heute
auszuräumen bei diesen fünf Messungen
sieht man tatsächlich innovative von
sechs Meter ca dass sich asymmetrischer
eisenmetallischer Gegenstand
einigermaßen senkrecht vielleicht ein
bisschen ein bisschen schräg im
Untergrund befindet das ist natürlich
für uns Indiz genug dass man sagen
müssen stoppt wir können hier nicht
freigeben sondern wir müssen es erst mal
schauen was es ist das machen die
kampfmittelräume heute noch wissen sie
nicht ob an dieser Stelle überhaupt
etwas Gefährliches liegt zunächst Graben
die Kollegen von der Baufirma mit dem
Bagger bis zu einer Tiefe von fünf
Metern kann nicht viel passieren
dichter am verdachtsobjekt übernehmen
dann die munitionsexperten
wir haben immer eben auch wie tief sie
gerade sind Messen immer wieder nach das
bedeutet dass immer noch so einen Meter
über verdachtspunkt
hergerichtet wird und dann die die
letzten Zentimeter oder letzte Meter
dann per Hand ausgegraben wird
dann entdeckt der Baggerfahrer etwas
Verdächtiges in der Baggerschaufel
davon hat sofort eine Vermutung
das Leitwerk befand sich am Heck der
Fliegerbombe fliegerbomben-
im ersten Moment ein verbogenes
Metallteil aber es schaut sehr noch
Fliegerbomben Netzwerk aus an der Größe
des des Displays an dem wie es
wie es geschnitten ist
schaut schon sehr
Verdächtiger nach Hause
ab jetzt übernehmen die kampfmittelräume
mit der Handsonde wollen Sie die
Position des verdachtsobjekts genauer
lokalisieren
nachdem sie vermutlich ein Leitwerk
ausgegraben haben ist es sehr
wahrscheinlich dass sie tatsächlich auf
eine Fliegerbombe stoßen Kanal
jetzt beginnt der anstrengende Teil die
kampfmittelrheuma müssen mit der Hand
weiter graben das ist sicherer als mit
dem Bagger
zunächst müssen Sie aber ein anderes
Problem in den Griff bekommen Wasser
hast du mir Grundwasser weiter absenken
ich schätze mal einen knoppen mit der
tiefer ungefähr werden wir noch sein das
werden wir alles herrichten dass im
Endeffekt das Wasser tiefer
abbrennen kann und dann werden wir den
letzten Meter
mit der Hand machen
die kampfmittelrheuma lassen Betonringe
in das Loch um einen sogenannten
Pumpensumpf einzurichten
die Ringe kommen an die tiefste Stelle
in der Gruppe anschließend leiten die
Experten das Wasser in die Ringe um es
darin abzupumpen
schließlich können Stefan und Thomas
anfangen zu graben ganz vorsichtig
stechen sie immer wieder vor
es kann vorher genau vor mir genau haben
wir genau hinter meinem hinter meinem
Schüler
[Musik]
liegt hier eine Bombe kann es gefährlich
werden wenn sie den Zünder treffen
vorsicht ist geboten
nicht nur deshalb kommen die
kampfmittelräumer langsam voran sie
kämpfen mit dem lehmigen Boden und mit
dem Wasser ist jetzt nicht extrem
tragisch es wird
und damit
ist jetzt eher eher technisches at
technische raffiness die da gerade ist
mit dem Wasser
kampfmittelräumer ist kein klassischer
Ausbildungsberuf Stefan pleiner kam über
das österreichische Bundesheer zur
munitionsbergung
die kampfmittelräume sind doch ein gutes
Stück von der Bombe entfernt sie
verlassen die Grube um weitere
Brunnenringe zu platzieren wir hätten
natürlich gehofft dass im Endeffekt die
Bergung ohne die Brunnenringe
funktionieren würde aber das Wasser war
dann doch zu stark genauer und ist immer
genug abgeflossen das heißt jetzt muss
er der Pumpensumpf dann neben den großen
brunnenringen neugierige Graben werden
nur ein bisschen tiefer damit das Wasser
aus den bodenringen schön raus fließen
kann und in den brunnenringen man
trocken arbeiten kann einen Meter müssen
die Männer noch tiefer graben
zurück zum Schmelzofen dem
gefährlichsten Arbeitsplatz in der
Eisengießerei Goslar er läuft seit über
vier Stunden die Schmelzer möchten
wissen ob das Eisen darin fertig ist nur
wenn die Temperatur stimmt können Sie
das Eisen Gießen
weil dann so ist um unsere schützen vor
Verbrennungen wir halten eine Menge
Hitze ab und auch die ganzen wenn es
spritzen sollte die Spritzer dann besser
mit Klima nicht ab
das Eisen hat jetzt eine Temperatur von
rund 1.500 Grad flüssig genug zum Gießen
eine Probe soll zeigen wie gut sie das
Rezept für den sphero-guss getroffen
haben
besonders auf den kohleanteil kommt es
an nicht höher als 4,4% dafür sein aber
auch nicht niedriger als 3,8
Prozent
ein bisschen länger brennen lassen damit
die Kohle mehr verbrennen Kohle und
Silizium heute passt alles
das sind sehr guter Wert sollte dann
Endeffekt so bei 2,4 sein nach dem
behandeln
Kohle Werte auch sehr gut die können so
bleiben also sehr zufrieden mit
die Pfannen sind vorgeheizt das Eisen
ist bereit zum Gießen
20 Minuten haben Sie gleichzeit um das
Eisen in die Formen zu füllen drei
Pfannen kommen zum Einsatz mindestens
sechs Personen brauchen Sie für den Guss
besser sind 7 falls ich eine verbrennt
der Regel weiß eigentlich jeder was er
zu tun hat also viel gesprochen wird
eigentlich nicht man muss relativ
konzentriert arbeiten insbesondere die
Radfahrer oder ähnlich das sieht man
gleich beim Übergießen dass ich da
einmal vertippt und irgendwo eine
falsche Richtung fährt dann kann er
natürlich tun
sehr heiß ist
dann geht es los
vor dem Gießen fehlt immer noch der
letzte Schritt für das perfekte Rezept
des ferocuses die Magnesium behandeln
eine Reaktion etwa wie bei einer
Wunderkerze
[Musik]
in der Pfanne das Eisen wird drüber
gegossen dass Magnesium reagiert mit dem
Sauerstoff
und zieht den Sauerstoff raus aber ich
habe eine höhere Oberflächenspannung was
sind bewirkt dass der Kohlenstoff dann
sich also
dadurch wird das Eisen später besonders
fest und lässt sich sogar leicht
schmieden der Kugel Graphit bleibt aber
nicht lange in seiner Form in 20 Minuten
muss das Eisen gegossen sein
die Strahlungswärme am Körper beträgt
bis zu 200°c
müssen Sie jetzt mit Eisen befüllen 4,5
Tonnen hat Andreas Jacobi dafür
berechnet gleich wird sich zeigen ob die
Menge passt
Herausforderung heute brauchen sie auch
die große Pfanne 2,5 Tonnen wiegt sie
ohne Inhalt
damit alles schnell geht gießen Sie an
mehreren Stationen gleichzeitig
Justus Siems führt die kleine Gießpfanne
[Musik]
genau jetzt noch ein Treffer damit es
halt dann nicht rausschmitz aber ab und
zu kleine spitzer sind leider nicht zu
vermeiden
auf das richtige Tempo kommt das an
gießen Sie zu schnell läuft das Eisen
über sind sie zu langsam können sich
Lufteinschlüsse bilden oder das Eisen
erkaltet schon in der Form besonders bei
der großen Pfanne ist da
Fingerspitzengefühl gefragt
zum Schluss nicht rechtzeitig
durchdrehen weil er abgelenkt ist oder
ähnlich ist noch nicht geguckt ganz
schnell passieren dass der Kasten
überläuft und hier verbrennen dadurch
dass wenn das rumspritzt in der Schule
geht oder ähnliches
nicht ohne
30 Grad sind es jetzt in der Halle im
Sommer wird es noch heißer
gegen 14 Uhr ist Feierabend
bei mir war damit zwei Kindern schön
wenn ich 30 Tage Urlaub und nur 35
Stunden arbeiten muss also ich kann mir
durchaus vorstellen dass auch entspannt
bis zur Rente zu machen der Körper
mitmacht aber da gehe ich bisher von
außen sozusagen noch keine Probleme
rund 30 Kilo Eisen bleiben heute übrig
die kommen morgen wieder in den Ofen
zusammen mit rund 4 Tonnen Roheisen wenn
die Schmelzer von Goslar den Ofen erneut
anfangen
Netphen im Siegerland 7 Tage brannte der
kohlemayer auf der einen Seite ist die
Kohle schon fertig
Köhler Reinhold Wagener musste in Meiler
nun durchhaken
kratzen nennt das Heu und Steine müssen
weg
[Musik]
wenn du da am Katzen bist fängt ja das
Abdeckmaterial man hat und es ist ja am
Glühen da fängt ja noch an zu glühen und
dann wird es natürlich noch heißer und
das ist schon die schwerste Arbeit
eigentlich
dass man Abkühlen ist
Maria Theresia Sting hilft dabei
die gelbe Erde
läuft ziemlich viel bei der Verkohlung
kann es im Meiler bis zu 800 Grad heiß
werden jetzt liegt die Temperatur am
inneren noch bei etwa 400 Grad
und durch das Wasser wird das etwas
abgekühlt
soll ja nichts verbrennen sondern nur
verkohlen denn wenn es verbrennt haben
wir nur noch Asche
zu viel Wasser darf aber auch nicht auf
den Meiler die Kohle kann sich
vollsaugen wie ein Schwamm
[Musik]
die Grillfreunde wollen ja keine Klasse
Kohle haben dann haben sie viel zu viel
Arbeit die
den Kühlern zu bekommen weil ich mache
hier nochmal drüber ich kotzen ein
bisschen durch das hier ein bisschen
kalt wird
das ist wie heißt die Nachricht
einen Trick gegen den Geruch von Feuer
im Kleidung und Haar haben Reinhold
wahrgenommen Maria Theresia Sting nicht
einfach duschen und stinkt normales
Waschmittel
man gewöhnt sich dran man gewöhnt sich
an den Qualm und alles
der Reinhold wollte mir damit schon mal
brauchen abgewöhnen hatte aber nicht
geschafft
ja du hast ja nicht richtig zu
mitgemacht du musst dich da oben mal
drauf stellen
ich mache nur einmal darüber gekriegt
hier noch mal drüber schön
ja so das ist ja schon gut und jetzt
kommt die Erde gleich drüber und alles
gut
bitte kalten Erde deckt Reinhold Wagener
den Meiler wieder ab das hilft
zusätzlich beim Abkühlen
jede Schaufel mit Erde wiegt rund acht
Kilogramm
immer über die Knie gehen und hier auf
dem Nil den Schaufel hast kannst du
hinten mit dem Griff runterdrücken und
mit der Hand hochziehen damit die hart
zu schwer die Schaufel noch weil du
machst dir das Hebelgesetz zu eigen und
dann kannst du das schön hier drauf
ziehen
der ist ja normalerweise von der Fläche
so riesig groß und muss da oben dann die
Erde drauf werfen da ist auch noch ein
Arbeit
so
17 Euro nimmt Reinhold Wagener für einen
Sack Kohle die Kosten decken kaum die
Ausgaben mit der industriell
hergestellten Kohle können nicht
konkurrieren allein das Holz kostet oft
mehr als die Kohle aus dem Markt
die Krone wird in einem großen Kessel
fremd erhitzt und das geht sehr schnell
da können die flüchtige Stoffe aus der
Cellulose aus dem Holz nicht so sauber
entweichen und bei meiner geht es
langsam und darum ist der
Kohlenstoffgehalt auch höher und da ist
dann entscheiden sage ich mal für die
geldfreunde die jetzt sag ich mal kühl
anmachen die haben dann
viel längere Glut eine Höhe Temperatur
um das Geld gut schnell durchzufahren
auf die nächste Charge Grillkohle aus
dem Meiler muss Reinhold Wagener noch
warten
heute kann er die Holzkohle noch nicht
ernten morgen dann bleibt noch ein
weiterer Abend mit Blick auf den Mailand
ganz beruhigendes Gefühl auch abends
wenn man die Arbeit gemacht hat und die
Löcher sind so schön aufgesteckt und der
raucht ja der Wind spielt so schön mit
dem Rauch wie gestern Abend saß ich noch
hier da gab es so kleine Luftwirbel
man hat jede Sekunde ein anderes Bild es
ist nie gleich und das ist so beruhigend
eigentlich man sitzt hier guckte mal
dazu wie er so vor sich hin raucht und
immer der Streben hat es muss gut werden
[Musik]
südlich von Wien gaben die
kampfmittelräume auf der Suche nach
einem Bombenblindgänger immer tiefer in
die Erde mittlerweile arbeiten Sie den
zweiten Tag auf der Baustelle gestern
mussten sie die Suche abbrechen der
lehmige Boden ist schwer und es riecht
immer stärker nach Benzin
Engel
alles klar es wird mehr
zweieinhalb Tausend Nano Tesla das ist
der Wert den das sogenannte Magnetometer
den kampfmittelräumern anzeigt
weit müssen die Munitionssuche jetzt
nicht mehr Graben weil wissen sie ob sie
etwas sprengkräftiges freilegen oder
Metallschrott
die Firma runterkommen der zerstärker
wird Ausschlag bei der Sonne ergo wir
nähern uns an
genau weniger wie sechs Meter tief ab
jetzt
noch ist die Laune gut aber die Arbeit
bleibt herausfordernd
damit das Problem wir müssen immer
wieder daneben
Graben auf ausheben Pumpe reinhängen
daneben und sowas ständig links rechts
links rechts
etwas mühsam wenn man die Sachen mit der
Hand raushilfen müssen aber
die Brunnenringe schützen die
kampfmittelrheuma falls ihr drei von den
groben Wänden herabstürzt
immer wieder sondieren die
kampfmittelräume nach Vorsichtsmaßnahmen
falls hier eine Fliegerbombe mit
intaktem Zünder liegt ja jetzt wird
langsam ja
schon so lange am Loch stehen dass das
langsam mittlerweile schon als Standard
eingebürgert hat dass er gespannt und
bin froh dass das hoffentlich heute
jetzt bald zu Ende ist und das Objekt
was es auch immer sein wird da heute
irgendwann einmal an entschärft an der
Baggerschaufel irgendwo da oben
auf der Gelände Oberkante baumelt
noch immer drängt zu viel Schicht Wasser
ein um es im brunnenring effektiv
Abpumpen zu können deshalb Graben die
erfahrenen munitionsberge einen Abfluss
unter den Betonring
du fließt das Wasser nach außen ab und
die Männer können erst außerhalb der
Regel abpumpen
[Musik]
weiter geht es nicht mit dem Baggern zu
gefährlich falls Sie eine Bombe liegt
um einen möglichen Zünder nicht
auszulösen gräbt Stefan vorsichtig mit
dem Spaten weiter
[Musik]
das ist die brennende Füllung
von Brandbomben auch Napalm genannt
also
und da kommt schon
diese Brennpaste raus dieses gelartige
Gemisch
aus
Diesel Benzin oder bei anderen
Stoffen die Amerikaner setzten Napalm
erstmals im Zweiten Weltkrieg als
Füllung von Fliegerbomben ein Napalm
brennt sehr heiß verursacht schwere
Verbrennungen und ist mit Wasser kaum zu
löschen
Brandbomben wurden mit einem oder zwei
Zündern ausgestattet
ja
ein Zünder
nur aktiv ist wenn sie Teil der
trainiert ist zum Beispiel es kann auch
sein dass sie aufgebrochen ist durch die
einschlagswucht und der Blindgänger ist
dann haben wir zwei intakte Zündsysteme
drauf
die kampfmittelberger bekommen immer
mehr von dem umweltschädlichen nahpalmen
in die Hände
viele Sprengstoffe sind giftig
Handschuhe sind deshalb für
kampfmittelräumer immer ein Muss
das Napalm ist noch entzündlich aber
nicht akut gefährlich
ob die dazugehörige Fliegerbombe noch
sprengkräftig ist wissen die
munitionsberger noch nicht
das ist die Hülle
dass sie aufgerissen ist
und dort tritt dieses
Gemisch Diesel Benzin
die Männer müssen die Bombe so weit raus
Graben dass sie den zünderstatus
begutachten können
im Idealfall kann die Bombe
abtransportiert und später vernichtet
werden nur im Ausnahmefall werden Bomben
vor Ort gespendet etwa Geschosse mit
langzeitzündern die zu entschärfen ist
zu gefährlich
was machen wir den ganzen Tag
irgendwohin stinkenden Löchern da im
Grund war es irgendwelche Sachen
ausgegraben muss man sichtlich
hätte was gescheites gelernt
komplett zersplittert
Stefan pleiner und seine Kollegen dürfen
Bomben nur freilegen identifizieren und
ihren Zustand begutachten entschärfen
darf nur der staatliche Entminungsdienst
Stefan trifft eine Entscheidung
[Applaus]
ich sag
ob jetzt mit der bedienungsdienst weiter
ob Blindgänger oder nicht kann man genau
sagen eher ein Teil der turnierer das
heißt hinten ist die definitiv
aufgeplatzt
es sind auch Splitter abgebrochen das
heißt es hat definitiv hinten eine
Detonation stattgefunden
sonst wenn es jetzt nur
auseinander gebrochen wäre aufgrund der
einschlag-energie dann wäre hinten nicht
die ganz markanten sprengsplitter am
Spuren sie schaut in diese Richtung
runter
aktuell geht von dem wie sie da jetzt
keine Gefahr aus wir wissen aber
trotzdem nicht was vorne drauf ist das
bedeutet
ab dem jetzigen Zeitpunkt müssen wir die
Polizei informiert Polizei und
Entminungsdienst sind schnell vor Ort
der entschärfer begutachtet das Geschoss
und beschließt die Bombe zu entschärfen
das bedeutet dass der Zünder
herausgedreht wird dadurch wird die
Bombe transportsicher gemacht
Stefan und seine Kollegen haben ihren
Job erledigt
Waffengesetz ist das genau die richtige
Vorgehensweise und somit als richtig
gemacht alles gut gegangen und die
Burschen haben alle super gearbeitet
trotz der widrigen Umstände mit Wasser
und Untergrund noch super funktioniert
Methan wird evakuiert schon nach 20
Minuten ist die Bombe bereit für den
Abtransport
[Musik]
die 250 Kilo schwere Brandbombe ist
nicht mehr akut gefährlich das Geschoss
wird beim Entminungsdienst
zwischengelagert und später in einer
sammelsprengung vernichtet
[Musik]
Stefan wirft einen Blick auf die
Fliegerbombe hier in mühevoller
Knochenarbeit ausgegraben hat
die körperliche
beanspruchen war doch enorm da ständigen
einen halben Meter Gatsch herum herum
warten und und
ist es Mittag
ins Büro gehen und dann geht der normale
Arbeitsalltag wieder ganz normal weiter
bis zum nächsten munitionsfund wird das
Gewissen nicht lange dauern noch
Jahrzehnte werden kampfmittelräumer
damit beschäftigt sein die Altlasten des
Krieges zu beseitigen von dieser Bombe
geht aber keine Gefahr mehr aus